[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the first
annual wrist of fury foosball tournament
at moon tower comedy festival
in austin baby we are so excited to have
you guys here today uh just a big shout
out to colleen and lisa for putting this
on give it up for them incredible
also special shout out to all things
comedy zodiac studios and voodoo donuts
go get some amazing donuts they're in
the corner they did a a foosball donut
cake and it's [ __ ] epic so uh go over
there and i'm so excited today to be
joined doing commentary on stage with
the amazing squad brother has given up
thank you thank you very much thank you
so much it's been a lifelong dream we
have been preparing for this day for our
entire lives kelsey and so uh we're
excited to be here we know the action is
going to be fast and furious we have
someone down on the sidelines who will
interview only the losers and some might
say everyone who's playing foosball
right now is technically a loser
we say no we say no only the loser's a
match he's like a white lisa salters we
of course bring to you josh adam meyer
thank you thank you very much everybody
i can only be here for 20 minutes
because i'm hosting a hungry hungry
hippo tournament after this
which is way more exciting than this
lame ass game josh uh a lot of people
don't know this josh still has cocaine
in his system and he's been sober for 10
months i am on a copious amount of
fentanyl guys but that's what you need
to get through this tournament josh has
never seen a pair of shorts that have
gone above his knees
[Laughter]
i'm a tiny man thank you
i am the brad williams of hosts
josh got really into crossfit so he
should be used to things that aren't
really sports
well we're excited for this uh this
match it's gonna be 32 uh contestants in
the first round and will continue to
pair down the winner of the tournament
then faces this champion right here
kelsey cook and the winner of that will
have the right to be named top chef
now a lot of people don't know this
about chelsea by the way i never
understood why that was such a good
thing like you just walk around telling
people excuse me i'm the top chef he's
like [ __ ] you jesus uh kelsey you're you
come from a family of foosballers uh i
don't know if everyone knows your
history but your mother is in the
foosball hall of fame is that correct he
is she's in the foosball hall of fame uh
my parents met playing in a professional
foosball tournament in the 80s so it's
in your blood i literally wouldn't exist
without this sad sport so in the
foosball hall of fame i ask you this
question when uh people go into the nfl
hall of fame they're given a golden
jacket when you go into the foosball
hall of fame i'm assuming it's just a
golden shower why would you even why
would you even i don't know
just imagine your mother getting a
golden shower before we get into the
action uh
let's go over the rules uh it's each
game is to what so we're playing a five
today
one game to five uh no spinning this is
not a fish concert guys
no spinning no spinning we gotta play
the rules right uh
any questions just raise your hand we'll
answer but that's what we're doing one
game to five we're going to whip through
this bracket and then the winner plays
me we're going to do an actual rissa
fury episode with the winner so we'll do
three rounds it'll be uh it'll be crazy
the punishment will be terrible if you
lose so should we get into the first
round what do you say what's that
i don't know if there's enough energy in
this room we need to get the energy up
this is the first annual foosball
tournament at the moon tower comedy
festival josh i'm going to add this is
the first and last annual foosball
championship
uh what do we say at the beginning
before do we say drop your balls or
let's foose also i want to say
they have the holes still in the tables
but technically now you start by placing
the ball on your five bar it's your
middle man you ask the other person if
they're ready they say ready and then
you can proceed usually you have to
touch two men wait a second but we're
just going to make it easy so then you
gently cup their balls
also rock paper scissors to start for
whoever gets the drop oh let's all right
so this is early gamesmanship
and brad williams scissors are kid
scissors i want you to know that they
are crayola sponsored on brad's table
little scissors
all right are we ready are we getting
ready so kelsey you want to just uh tell
them let's boost and start this thing
off are you guys ready oh it's like
devil 2 is underway let's face it
all right so when we say
the terrorists have taken away our
freedom you see something like this and
you say no we're coming back
look at brad williams showing an
incredible amount of skill on uh table
one it's like
again showing you that arm length has
nothing to do with being able to play
this game that's right he's almost too
tall on that chair i would argue he is
fully uh i've often said this about brad
he thinks he's a lot taller than he is
right is spine angle something you want
to be focused on there's a goal right
away
through with the first goal
this is heated
wait what's going on there
what's what's happening with this guy
zero
yeah billy wayne davis has nothing
nothing else says nothing it's something
his his wife has heard him say over and
over again in his marriage billy davis
has nothing he's also losing to zero god
look at this guy wow
the what do we call that move to kelsey
the side and then the sun are there
started as a euro pen right it's a euro
pin and then he went around i'm guessing
this is an old school foose guy here why
is gabriel iglesias trying to lift the
table up on table four
action on table one brad williams trying
desperately not to get skunked tell us
about it no one wants to get skunked in
this sport it's a terrible feeling oh
and it happened sent to an early grave
brad williams josh adameyers is going to
talk to you we only interview the losers
josh
i've never said this about someone who's
lost a foosball match help him down from
his chair
brad uh billy
first of all what happened out there
listen as someone who's about the same
size as my players i thought i could
coach them up but they were not
listening to me brad i was waiting for
you to get on the table i really was we
were hoping you would be able to kick
the ball in yourself will you fuse again
i love how josh adam meyers is holding
the microphone so low that even i have
to bend down again
you a-hole
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i believe billy wayne davis true
champion billy wayne davis did you lose
billy wayne
we lost gracefully is is foosball a
redneck sport or is it something that uh
hasn't made its way into the hinterlands
i
i don't know it is the most white trash
sport i think yeah i was gonna say like
it's not redneck it's like white trash
white dress
and white trash can be i mean you're an
oakland a's fan so white trash can be
anywhere hey we're scrappy you're
scrappy i think i think foosball is like
it's like if you can't
afford darts
what darts seems cheaper uh billy are
you saying if you can't afford darts
emotionally yes okay okay all right low
risk you you i know you're not drunk but
you seem drunk i just want to say that's
going on i appreciate that i truthfully
i'm just happy he has all of his teeth
billy wayne davidson davis everybody
this cannot be said for all gracious
great comic
oh yeah we've got two new matches coming
up so let's call it scott all right on
table
one
we have dan soder against marcus portman
dan soder everybody dan soda off the
bonfire in an attempt to pay tribute to
oh my god that is a power move so dan
soder thought he was going to have the
height advantage and then this guy shows
up and literally gets up on the chair
power move
it's interesting because it that was a
power move but he is known in around his
relationship as a zzz bottom folks yes
cz bottom
so rock paper scissors rock paper
scissors shoot
here we go oh boy best of three already
with her
okay
wow
this is way more exciting than the food
oh that's all i don't think they should
play finally some drama he's already in
soder's head on table one already in his
head with the best two out of three
not to get in sutter's head more who won
on that back table do you want you want
you oh my god come over here come on
fluffy talk to him come over here fluff
fluffalophagus
so when you're not playing sax in a jazz
trio
how do you get your foozing you told me
about she's like if you win this is
gonna be you boom and she crushed that
ball she crushed that ball that she
broke so it's intimidating so i was like
uh i i just gave up that was an ivan
drago moment and you emotionally kind of
had the wind taken out of your sails
yeah it's hard to come back from that
it's hard to be emasculated like that on
a foosball table yeah and i've only got
the one left so i had to you only had
one ball left we understand we
understand we get it uh what's next for
you i mean i'm talking about this
afternoon where are you going i'm trying
to get in that hungry hungry hippo thing
hey we're all hungry we have the buffalo
wild wings on fourth street i have a
feeling i'll be better at that i have i
have one final question who are you
wearing
this is a gabrielle shot but it's last
season okay gabriel iglesias tommy
bahama thank you so much thank you so
much
thanks buddy we got dan soder officially
out josh out of myers talk to pulp
fiction over here oh first first answer
dan what happened out there i was
playing for the uh homeless children of
austin foundation so now they can't eat
oh wow what a lot i hope he feels good
dan i love that you're gripping a
microphone the way you'd never grip it
ever i just want everyone to know i had
a great time you're way too close to the
bike
dan dan that was a valiant effort you
got some points in in there you scored
some goals yeah whatever man this whole
thing is fixed
[Music]
this is now the third time that sodar
has lost on risk of fury which is a new
record for the show so give it up to
damn dance soda everybody
so dan is dan the most talented loser
you've seen because he definitely has
some skill but he loses every single
time he comes alive on the table
terrible motor skills dan the foosball
arena is the last place i'd expect to
hear conspiracy theories so keep that
[ __ ] out of here uh pulp fiction come on
up
josh is gonna talk to you yeah he lost
on table three before i i you know i'm
not really understanding the shirt short
combo but maybe you can help us out are
the socks
you know what i'm uh
i'm really i'm okay with losing today
why is that
i'm just having a good time at the first
foosball ever
this is not the first foosball ever but
yes that's fine foosball has been around
for thousands of years first foosball to
ever happen this is the first foosball
to ever happen i just love how present
you are sir
thank you easy eckhart tolle of foosball
ladies and gentlemen you know for him
life is like pulp fiction it doesn't
have to follow a normal timeline
[Laughter]
someone please get in a shot of
adrenaline to his heart as he sits down
over there who lost down here on table
two oh no
wow the women are dominating so far get
over here tim i'd love to see it yeah
i love it tim uh what happened out there
buddy
birds aren't real and neither is
foosball
birds are dinosaurs tim so before we
start getting into a discussion about
that do you regret the decision to wear
jeans on a day like today i regret
nothing you get nothing
so you accept your loss and you're
willing to concede no it wasn't a real
game oh wow jesus christ you see what
trump has done guys yeah joking like a
true man who lost to a woman
facts stop this field
stop to steal stop no stop the steal of
that game
just of that game just eventually won
the election okay
all right you know what i can get on
board with that uh good luck man you're
gonna have a lot to think about tonight
as you move on in a life of foosball
so so are are you obviously
there's a women's bracket and a men's
bracket when it comes to professional
foosball but this is a game that you
know i feel like men and women can match
up on an amateur level pretty well
correct i think so yeah you said it's an
issue of power and speed at the highest
levels though some of these dudes come
in and they are
roided up like really really
jacked down yeah and
is there drug testing in the game
i don't think so it's foosball has a lot
of drugs involved there's a lot of drugs
look at the hat of the gentleman on
table four you want to talk about drugs
that's a guy who on a very very drug
bender decide to make a fashion choice
he's the he's the relic hunter yes
sir how many uh
how many items have you picked up for
nicholas cage
[Laughter]
four skulls how's that going uh it went
pretty good right
how'd you feel out there i mean there
was like a moment where i felt like you
were gonna kick it into overdrive and
then again i saw those sunglasses and
i'm like this is the highest gear he's
got yeah i felt good until he said he
had one in his basement
a buried body you could have been a
child i think he's from cleveland okay
so uh will you foose again i guess is my
question i think so one day you think so
yeah i love how not confident what do
you do for a living sir i make websites
of course you make websites and you live
in austin that's the first time i've
ever heard that guys
i didn't think this was a tech town at
all jeez uh you guys should check out
dell computers they're amazing um
they're the wave of the future what's
the best website you've made recently
i can't tell you you can't tell me porn
biz wiki
okay well thank you thank you for being
so thank you for being so forthcoming
thank you for being such a free-flowing
interview
[Applause]
josh you have anything to add
uh no all right this guy just kills all
the energy before we bring more people
to the table
this guy's queueing on 100 all right
he's got theories uh so we've had eight
we've had eight competitors or sorry 16
people have played so far is that right
two rounds on these tables uh kelsey
what have you seen so far from these
competitors and are you worried knowing
that you have to play a champion who who
out of this first group gives scares you
strikes a little fear in you i didn't
get to see enough what was happening on
table four but whoever who has the table
in their basement
someone has a table in their basement
they made quick work of some i i think
the person who defeated brad williams on
table one and he's standing over there
by the bar and he's giving you a side
eye that's a guy who who i feel like has
walked into this tournament is like i
feel like i can win it all yeah he's got
confidence i'm a little worried about
him he had some good shots from the back
so we will see so what are we playing
can you show us what we're playing for
today as as far as the trophies are
concerned right there the the hardware
is right on the table these are my
trophies these are your trophies that
you've won we brought these from the set
in la okay so these are your trophies
will the winner get one if they beat you
i don't think i could [ __ ] handle
that you couldn't give that up i
couldn't give that these are your babies
i understand in your heart of hearts
right now do you expect to win
your final match be honest
i think so but i don't
there are people here who could be
hustling me because texas is a big
foosball state and so maybe some of you
showed up and you've played for a long
time and austin's a food austin's a
foosball city are we right i mean if
we're talking in san antonio it's more
papa shot and i'm talking about open
carry so um
that's right all right so we uh let's
get more let's get eight more players on
the table uh ladies and gentlemen kelsey
cook by the way she's going to play the
champion
[Applause]
that's right and kelsey what are we
seeing okay so okay there's a there's
some moves there's a guy in the back
here right now on table two
in the texas shirt yeah he kind of looks
like he knows what he's seeing some ball
control there is some ball and there's a
flow between him going from offense to
defense he seems to know what he's doing
in some weird way
nice black nice block he's using the guy
in the red has a mean left hand from the
back i don't know if you're seeing that
he does have a mean left hand from the
back and i wish it would be nicer guys
we don't have to be that mean
lefties have a little bit of an
advantage sometimes why is that because
you're not as used to playing them and
so the way he's shooting from the back
the very very back man people are not as
ready for that right and he can hit it
very hard from the five bar which not
all people can do oh
strong goal coming from table two guys
we have a real competitor here to the
back is it one zero
one one so take a point on your side
there you go
oh god all right
kelsey don't mansplain it too
well he's not taking a [ __ ] point i
know now you understand what it's like
it's like [ __ ] yeah
now you know what we feel like when
people oh
what did i say big goal big goal
there's a lot of talent wait wait red
shirt front rope table two you just gave
him a point
yeah so do your way there we go
there we go i'll let you guys mansplain
we're doing our best
we've been trying to mansplain since
1984.
uh we're banned here one zero two zero
hunter duncan and maybe the most gentle
goal of all time
whispered it in
full consent full content on that goal
full consent on the goal he got it he
actually got it
in writing yeah she said may i please
and again
maybe this should happen more often may
i please score on you and she said yes
she actually emailed back yes and then
he sent her a docusign
to which the she had to sign up for
docusign she's like i don't know if i
can do that
table two is we have two two so there's
a moment when in these early rounds when
you're like oh man these two both
competitors are great it's a shame one
of these guys has to leave and then i
would argue take it one step further
it's a shame that one of those people
have to be taken out back in shock so
the losers in these early rounds are
murdered in the back absolutely we
should let people know that again open
carry in texas they're okay with it
they'll murder anything here except for
an unborn fetus guys we're having a
great time
hey guys it's a foosball game it's it's
not a choice it's right
when is a foosball game a game when you
drop the ball or when it goes in guys
there we go another goal that was that
was tough
we have a close game on table two
3-3 an epic game on table this is duke
north carolina on table 2. this is a lot
of anger a lot of aggression we got
rachel who's maybe about to win on table
three rachel oh
audible anger from rachel on table three
it's 4-4 over there we got some good
great matches
down to one point
the women have really come to play today
and i appreciate that me too
as a father of two daughters i really
appreciate that and by women you are
referring to hunter duncan i am flip
flops and painted toenails
i think that one just might be a dead
toad we're one point away from uh
from the steel right here texas looks
like he's about to go down that's late
that's hunter duncan's uh new year
rachel let's get you over here rachel oh
that was a nail biter i want to hear
what happened first of all richie really
good have you you've played foosball
before obviously no you've never won
only once how are you this good at it
he's just really bad too he's really bad
too uh did you have fun out there
texas all right oh my god everybody here
is playing for the first time today guys
this is there is no skill involved in
this game whatsoever are you joking josh
josh you're insulting her family and
everything josh is bitter because he
just lost to me and risk of fury a
couple days ago i scored two goals on
you how did that go though in the end i
mean i lost of course but there you go
so you're an olympic level athlete at
this all right josh has some interviews
to do rachel thank you for joining us
thank you rachel for everything where's
our next loser all right tex mexicans
get over here tax max and chill what
happened out there it was rocky
i couldn't be happier that i lost in the
first round of a foosball tournament i
mean you're going to take that with you
i'll actually have a life now well no
but i mean you're going to take that
with you for a long time first of all
your nipples are so erect right now it
is insane we could do it i could cut
glass on them i could cut voodoo donuts
with those nipples so and you're clearly
aroused by the loss but
you have a great left-handed shot
and i mean you've obviously played
foosball before are you mad at the
match-up you got in the first round
because some people got an easy draw and
you got it
it's a fun game yeah you do it for the
love of the game and you do it for and
you are donating all of your proceeds
today to charity am i right you do it
for the kids not your kids just some
kids you've been hanging out afghan
football club alliance that's right
there we go wait i'm gonna tell you this
right now when you're allowed to get
back within 500 yards of the school i
think those kids are going to appreciate
you're going to do a lot of good at that
point
uh where what do you do for a living
just out of curiosity uh own a
recruiting company okay great see he
likes to recruit kids we got it we
understand
uh great you actually really played well
it was it was a pleasure to watch you uh
do what you do out there today good luck
to you thank you so much who's our next
loser at ah
we were rooting for you uh what happened
out there uh he was just better
wow that's usually how
this works uh will you be fusing again
or is this the end or maybe the
beginning of your foosball career
i'm gonna have to take some time i have
a non-foosball related question how do
you get the pink to stay in your hair
for a long period of time uh conditioner
conditioner
you just can't wash it enough am i right
right you just gotta make sure that your
hair is not washed jesus christ randy
why are you begging oh my kids love to
put the stuff in their hair i just want
to gather some information thank you
just trying to be out of the air
uh did you enjoy it have you ever played
foosball before a couple times okay
great how was today in comparison to the
other times you played he's a beast he
is a beast he's a beast he is a beast
hunter that's the first time hunter's
ever been called a beast in any area of
his life that is a gentle man in the bed
he's a very very gentle man he's very
very very helpful he's an ally as we
like to say yeah
so
thank you for playing we appreciate you
i hope you this doesn't turn you off to
the game for your life
come back and play foosball again give
her a round of applause this is the big
shock that this guy if there was anyone
that i ever would have thought that
would have been good at foosball
it was a man wearing a bretta hitman
heart shirt i'm going to call you dana
off-white
i've heard that before okay really
you've heard that before not off-white
but i've heard dana white you're the
type of guy that wears water shoes
nowhere near water
[Laughter]
what happened out there bud it was a
humiliating defeat what was the score
the score was four one i believe and i
scored on myself twice you scored on
yourself
that's called masturbation yeah you look
like you score on yourself every night i
feel at that as well so hey all right
are you in a relationship right now yes
i am well very nice thank you what's her
name laura oh nice and where's she was
her i really don't know hi laura hi
laura are you proud look at her she's
proud of you she's proud that you
competed and you left it all on the
table yes yes i didn't bring much so
where are you guys going tonight uh
we're going to see dan at seven oh nice
fantastic it's gonna be a great show
yeah
and i guess we'll guys we'll just get
dinner at clark's the four of us later
okay guys that's nice that's nice
have a great time thank you for joining
us thank you so much buddy so sometimes
you you
you end up
running into a buzz saw and that's what
this guy did so we saw a lot more talent
not a lot more talent but we saw some
people that might be able to challenge
you in this round one person who went
out uh the the sweat wicking red shirt
of the gentleman over there that's going
to be something that you're going to
have to go up against how are you
feeling right here yeah texas shirt
look at him just standing in the sun
he doesn't even care
that guy hasn't seen a a bottle of
sunscreen in a long time and the fact
that i called it a bottle of sunscreen
shows you where you are tube of
sunscreen i don't know
anyway uh so are you okay so let's call
out the uh
tables going yeah
all right
okay very good all right all right
it's quite possible that he pronounced
both those names wrong
terribly
all right i told you not to give me a
microphone all right on table three
uh felix
uh
from jfl oh my god
uh and he's playing ballsy
this is what happens if you're this
guy's he's mexico city
he this he doesn't sweat this gentleman
right here
you don't have to take oh we weren't
asking for that we weren't asking for it
but now that you did mexican john mayer
is gonna [ __ ] rip it up
his body is a wonderland and you're
gonna find out all about it i was gonna
say mexican morrissey but isn't that
just
about morrissey all right felix will be
playing
justin hodge
where's justin hi uh you can run but you
cannot hide
on table four
we have jt kelly against sawyer stoltz
okay here we go we got a ball game
excitement this is happening oh my god i
haven't seen this much beard on beard
action
since nicole kidman fought katie holmes
all right every once in a while we get
one in all right
every once in a while we move the old
thing
okay
by the way the beard the beard's on
table four both of them look like
they're wearing disguise
[Music]
they both look like woody allen and
bonanzas
table one we have a match of two losers
from earlier because we have an open
spot two brads brad grossman brad
williams okay
brad is resurrected from the dead so we
gotta get that chair for brad again so
for bro i don't think you need a chair
brad i love that you tried to say that
before and you're trying to play the
card like you need help did he win he
doesn't have his opponent we actually
are missing the opponent on tape so i
think we should pull dan soder off the
mat and
plug dan into this match right here can
we get
let's get dan soder up there
[Music]
all right
i just like getting dan soder involved
in anything dan soder tonight at seven
right where are you i'm at the state
theater okay fill it up you guys for dan
soder i don't want to say i don't want
to say dan soder is high but he said
it's so nice to be here at south by
southwest
all right brad williams
brad grossman brad brad waves is rock is
so small it's a pebble let's go guys
yeah brian williams paper is so small
it's a post-it note
so rock paper scissors
[Laughter]
all right here we go here we go these
are real opportunities redemption for
both brad williams on table one and dan
soder on table and brad grossman and
brad grossman
these all feel like very exciting
matches to me this round right
we've got the beards we've got the brads
uh-oh there you go he's got one got one
brad grossman come on
use everything that you've got out there
did soder just pass to his five bar that
was very impressive so so so this is the
thing what do you see when you see like
a little move done by someone or you're
what is the tell that this person has
played foosball before how they pass
between the same line or between
different lines there's very uh
very intentional movement so you're not
just wildly hitting it or hitting at an
angle you have a purpose to me that's
always what i can tell if somebody's
played before all right here we go back
table looks like it's close back there
josh what are you seeing down on table
four i'm seeing uh one of the
competitors on table four uh literally
wearing his uh night pants to perform
covered in dog hair which is a good sign
there is lucky i mean the best part
about that is he does not have a dog
this is all from i guess the right side
of his face the question is whose dog
was it
dan soder with a quick goal
brad brad grossman takes another step
forward here that we've got looking for
redemption the battle of the brads up
front
feels like where it feels like a
notebook here guys the battle of the
brads brad is going chairless on this
match ladies and gentlemen and he's
going hairless on his balls so here we
go
fresh wax
where'd you go to college brad grossman
are you trying to talk [ __ ] to me while
i'm up here saying i'm awful he's awful
dude he's always one away you're one
away from moving on to the next round so
so is brad williams right or no he's
only got one goal he's only got one goal
hey jay remember when you told bradley
williams to not stand on a chair bad
idea sorry
i'm trying to oh brad williams look look
for the shot oh
it's getting hot on table one let's move
to table one yeah let's check out table
one there we go we got the action up top
looking in on the big screen behind us
brad williams
brad grossman lining up the shot and oh
off to the side brad williams with a
deep shot trying good defense by brad
right now but he just passed in oh god
so it what's a what's a good
strategy on defense you obviously want
to stagger your two and your and your
you want to stagger your men
to obviously cover as much of the goal
as possible oh brad williams big goal
for brad williams on table one
he's fighting his way back in dan soder
with another goal he's he's two away
table two the action's hot and heavy
let's take a look at it from up above
can i do my favorite rose joke about
brad williams that we did when we were
when we roasted him in montreal sure
what does a roller coaster and a good
comedy show have in common what if you
see brad williams on either you're like
should he be here okay folks
thank you kelsey
oh wow
beards are fighting on
oh please embrace me josh get over there
get over there and let's talk let's get
the loser over here dog hair get over
here dog hair
so i hate to say it but what are you
drinking a little hair of the dog
this is a vodka soda your voice is
exactly the way i was expecting it
this is
and where will you be seeing my morning
jacket next
never heard of it
so
when you're not
i can't
wait
[Laughter]
when you're not inventing toys for
children what do you do i'm a
telemarketer yeah there you go that
couldn't be a more perfect job that's a
pleasant voice i'd like to hear your
voice that voice comes into my ears i'm
sticking around i want to buy what
you're selling i've never said this
before but tell a marketer you got the
pants for it
uh what do you tell a market
uh i sell websites there you go oh so i
know someone who can build them for you
yeah i do too actually you do i know you
guys are interested we can talk after
this let's talk he's marketing to us
right now
yeah really let's talk right now for an
hour about
well 15 minutes but yeah what kind of
website let's get into it what kind of a
website what are we good ones not good
ones not expensive ones though is it all
flash just guys i don't want to get into
website talk here but it's uh
i just tell you it does like it's like
you know how you can sell stuff online
and get drop shipped yeah yeah it's that
but it's expensive i want to get in the
weeds about yeah that's right all the
details all right no no
his websites are so bad they're htm i
sell them i don't know how to i don't
even know what that means
he said put a link in the email and her
vagina dried up all right here we go
uh thank you thank you so much
brad williams uh we hate to be
interviewing you yet again what happened
uh it's a it's an honor to be talking to
you after the host of forged and fire
yeah
uh yeah i lost twice today it's okay
brad the man
no not at all you you fought really hard
and you scored some great goals and you
had good defense it was just an
onslaught from the other brad right it
it absolutely was i'm rooting for the
other brad in the tournament brad
support other brands all right good also
that guy can book you at cap city we get
it we [ __ ] out here get out of here
on table uh this gentleman right here
what happened buddy
oppression oppression
god that's the truth you don't you don't
see a lot of dreadlocks in foosball and
there's a reason god damn it not at all
they don't make it easy not at all i
mean there's the one diversity quota
higher here i uh
i don't like it either i uh yeah they
could have just let me through but we
put in dan soder the white man here
dan soder so dan soder's so white he's a
possession i just want to apologize for
winning i'm sorry
i don't know what it's like i just i'm
so sorry i was born into this position
okay hey
guys
there's there he called me king after
every shot
and look we've been saying this all
along critical foosball theory needs to
be taught in schools we have said that
over and over again i didn't like that
he picked you up after the match but
from behind and said
that was a little pejorative if you ask
me
will you foose against her [ __ ] no all
right that's the answer
[Applause]
my sociology professor from junior
college is here
literally love him so much
he just said hi he just said hi what
synagogue are you thinking
[Laughter]
no how many golf shirts that look
exactly like that do you own oh a lot a
lot exactly they're comfortable look
there
they're comfortable question would you
wear that golf shirt to a funeral if you
would
no i would not okay good
uh what do you do sir i'm retired air
force yes there you go thank you for
your service and i mean not in the not
in the armed service for what you did
today on that foosball table
it was yeah what was the problem why did
you lose so badly poor eye hand
coordination
first of all you're calling it eye hand
coordination most people go the other
way and that's the problem exactly well
there he goes i'm old i mean is that
what they teach you in the air force
it's all eye hand coordination in the
air force well obviously i didn't fly
that's right you obviously didn't fly
uh did you would you call upon your
military training in moments like these
to just buckle down and say okay i can
get through this yeah i mean i did the
best i could i got two points but you
did just the fact that you called him
points instead of goals tells us why you
lost uh there you have it but we
appreciate your service we really do
thank you so much uh thank you you might
have lost the game but you definitely
won the contest for longest chest hair
i've ever seen
in my life that is a lot can i have that
no no josh take it easy it's so long
josh just i don't want to say it was
long but josh just took it and made a
lanyard out of it
give it up for this competitor ladies
and gentlemen you're amazing amazing and
a great sport he'll you can see him
later at itt tech
teaching wood shop
all right so we're into round two are
you guys having fun let's see
so far i love this kelsey are you having
fun so far
okay and you're you're seeing the talent
that's coming up your way how you
feeling like if you you know how like
you do a set of comedy and if it's not
going well you just start to flop sweat
yeah or maybe that's just me you're not
sweating at all right now based on the
competition you're seeing i need to see
what happens in round two okay so round
one a lot of the pretenders are gonna
they dropped off all the people who
thought it was funny to just join and
now we've got now we can see what's
actually happening we've got all the
contenders and dan soder i get it okay
so
shall we let's call to the tables the
next group
okay on table one back
yeah all right against seth elbot okay
here we go this is where it starts to
get real yeah this is gonna be great
table two we have matt bryant against
terry cordova
round two this is round two
uh table three
logan anderson against marcus bortmann
hello
okay this is the woman that literally
broke the ball she's just out there
breaking balls over here i love that she
came from a table where her drink could
have gone still brought it up here yes
and her mask and her purse
no one's stealing your stuff nobody's
gonna don't getting your things okay get
a drink she might she look i'm this way
too in all bar games i play better drunk
on table four we have nick half power
against ryan scott okay don't forget to
rock paper scissors for the opening ball
drop
okay we already got the accent going you
want to rock paper scissors for the
opening ball drop okay speaking of ball
drop josh and meyer's balls just dropped
a week ago so give him a round of
applause
for all the great work he's done with
kids
josh any new tattoos
no no new tattoos i think i'm done i've
got all my sports teams but i will be
getting the winner's face tattooed on my
so the winner of this guy
so take a look at this face right here
you're going to be getting it on your
buttocks
okay good can i take kelsey on my butt
all right so we're looking at okay
little action
so we have two of the promising women in
in this in this round on table three and
on table two yeah part of me wanted to
see them go up against each other no i
do i actually don't i don't want to see
a lot of we want to see one of them
advanced exactly that's why i said they
go against each other then it guarantees
one of them goes into the third that's a
great point randy why are you
questioning me i don't know because i
believe both of them can win their
matches okay there's a lot of action
going on here the ball seems to be oh
wow i was watching uh the guy closest to
us on table four yeah warming up earlier
very good yeah used to play with one of
the hall of fame football players terry
roo wow or no terry moore i think terry
moore may terry moore rest in peace i
know he's not dead but i just want him
to get a good night's sleep
i've seen some really good player
movement over here on table two
ball control if you can see what he's
doing with his hand it's extremely
creepy he's jiggling the ball
hey josh out of myers that's nuts
it's ballistic uh what's going on on
table three where what's the score over
there on three three we've got a
i think it's two nothing
zz bottom rocking it
and i mean this is literally he's he's
dedicating every performance to billy
gibbs
wow
uh this gentleman down here who looks
like he owns a 1997 subaru is destroying
him i thought he looked more like john
prine
may he wrestle the deep cut steve kite
all right also table four is the guy i
believe who owns a table yeah he owns
this table in his basement he's up to oh
so this is table in his basement up 2-0
look at him he's
one this gentleman down here
okay this is your dude kelly this is
your dude this is your dude okay
this is he's got a sponsorship deal with
asics he is built for foosball he has no
muscle mass on his body yeah he's put on
three pounds this year none of it josh
he's got a two figure deal with orvis
we need a ball
the win
by the way
oh my lord
okay are we one go it's okay
you're allowed to curse ma'am you're
allowed to curse yes you are i would
take a long sip on that drink ma'am oh
wow i thought that was in oh wow shot
balls flying on table two
a lot of anger balls are flying and
she's in a relationship with someone
else i just need to she is wasted right
now guys i hear a lot of giggling
she's trying to call this guy
five oh five oh you guys
oh all right josh talk to him we might
have a ringer in seth but let's talk to
this competitor that went down that baby
got back
what happened out there what happened
because you handled your first round
pretty easily and then you ran into a
buzzsaw i i wanted to play with the
black ones
oh
can we call that cultural appropriation
definitely i'll play with the chinese i
ain't winning [ __ ] do you know my idea
that you know how they have the kiss cam
at stadiums i want to play like hardcore
gangster rap in like basketball arenas
and just take the camera around to
people you know like at the kids cam
they have like two dudes kissed at the
end and it's homophobic and terrible
just get like people singing it anytime
they drop an n word and then cut to a
white guy singing it's the cultural
appropriation camp let's do that
hey listen uh i i just want to say this
and and i don't want to quote someone
like this but there are good people on
all sides i do believe that there are
good people on all sides so you never
quote you were fantastic man there was
no i went further than the other black
guy i'm good hey that's all you needed
today guys let's not make it a
competition
hey thanks for joining us man thank you
so much buddy
i'll say this about you even though you
lost your name is bak you will you will
be back all right
always always
great attitude great player who lost on
three we lost on table three oh no she's
got such good pockets show them how high
your pockets are on those shorts look at
that your pockets are higher than josh
adam meyers at burning man jesus christ
[Applause]
that's coming from you i know that's me
i mean you you have what what appears to
be a perfect foosball outfit you've got
headphones whose headphones are those
are those yours actually it's the ac
that's an ac thing that's it
so you're keeping your neck cool what
happened you came out with so much
promise in round one and here you are
we're no one's disappointed in you but
we're shocked yeah well look i expected
better for myself but um i really hope
that guy that i crushed earlier is happy
that i lost now yeah um but you know i'm
surprised i made it around too i am
proud of you for making it to round two
you have a lot to be proud of you can do
anything you want in this world
especially in these shorts
if you were selling me a website in
those shorts i'd buy it by the way we're
getting we're coming hey josh we're here
josh hannah myers thank you so much
congratulations josh edemeyer's maybe
not
okay this game is heated down you have a
heated game on game two i mean you're
seeing hard shots you're seeing balls
ricochet everywhere you're seeing set up
shots defense you're seeing a lot of
emotional anger you know this is anger
that usually gets eaten that's right
all right she's back to her back row
she's passing it back up
she's backed up
wow this hot action are we watching up
top okay oh there it goes i smelled a
five bar shot coming wow
thank you so much
that was one of the most are you walking
off a winner who lost she won you won
oh my gosh oh my god he's already broken
one ball settler down jesus christ yes i
love it what does it feel not only to
lose but to get melanoma today
oh sorry your test results just came in
you are you did test positive this guy
has never put sunscreen on uh sir that
was an epic battle and you were up at
the beginning what did you get
complacent over confidence you're
looking at wet in my eyes you're not
supposed to sweat in foosball i know
there's no
tom who said that tom hanks said that
there's no sweating in foosball
absolutely he said no
he said i'm david pumpkins i believe
this is what he said uh will you foose
again sir i mean you had a nice showing
and i think you can we'll be back next
year you'll be back next year i'm going
to say this in the manual second annual
baby in the truest way i'm getting lost
in your dimples right now i love you you
are beautiful
he is glistening right now i mean
and ladies
ladies he's single am i right are you
single no married okay whatever we can
get we can get rid of her easily i saw a
couple of guys with beards that know how
to dispose a body okay
and they have a website for that they do
congratulations man you're amazing thank
you for playing great job man we'll see
you again next week josh that was an
amazing game josh an amazing game
but it proves that the more you drink at
this game the better the better you'll
be is that true kelsey is that true does
drinking a lot of bud light early in the
morning on baseball tournaments cheetos
fritos pbr cheetos fritos pbr that to me
that that by the way could be made if
you told me that was a number one hit
for florida georgia line i'd be like
yeah
cheetos fritos
if you told me jews will not replace us
was the number one hit for georgia
florida i'd be like yep probably uh bud
ice feels like it should be sponsoring
this ice house beer anyway what we're
about to say kelsey we need to interview
this man because i have to know what
happened on table 4. come on did you
lose come on
so obviously you're disappointed
obviously things are going through your
mind you wore your magic sword shirt
which made sure that no woman would ever
come close to you i appreciate that
what uh what happened oh man ryan's
legit
legit he is his name's ryan
yeah ryan's got a table in his basement
looking at you he's uh
he's up there on the what does he shoot
uh he's doing pulse mostly mostly pull
shot okay
really good really good pickup game he
was
picking up the loose balls how about his
mental game was he was he trying to
psych you out in a minute how much of
your ice how much is foosball and maybe
this is a question for kelsey is between
the ears
it's a lot okay it's a lot of focus you
can't blink
i was uh yeah a little nervous
are you i'm gonna ask this seriously are
you on suicide watch right now
does somebody need to hang out with you
tonight
will someone hold your hair back when
you're drinking later that's not our
problem okay good thank you we got it we
can put some on and and uh you will
foose again i'm sure you were a really
good player for sure okay great it's
nice to hear it don't quit thank you so
much buddy give it up for him and all
the competitors that have moved on and
lost that's right but the losers are
actually the winners today that's right
in some ways they are uh that's a good
guy cut him off he doesn't need any more
drinks uh nice to see josh and myers
wrapping the st patrick's day
today
good to see you there uh great action on
that right there some winners who we
didn't expect you start to see the
competition rise to the top this
gentleman who beat bach back over on
table one he's someone to look out for
uh are we into the third round ryan is
someone to look out for the second half
of the second second half of the second
round this is fun are you guys having
fun so far we're still in this right
crowd
crowd is pumped yeah we're ready let's
bring them up to the table
this is a game to do oh cool now if i
win i'm not going to get booked at any
helium that's right
it's a shame table 2 hunter
you're back up against david smith this
is an international match
table four felix's
sawyer raul what's your last name
what's rival's last name
campos delgado campo set raul campos
delgado is basically the dave smith of
mexico
it's one of the most common names in
mexico campos delgado
all right uh table two i'm really
expecting uh hunter duncan not to get
one goal here
his flip-flops are telling me his mind
is not in this
you don't mess with texas i'll say that
yeah guy on table two in the texas shirt
looks like he has strangled a cat before
by the way i'm just getting in my ear
today is officially we have broken the
record for most people watching foosball
at one time that's right it surpassed
the record of six which we never thought
we would do in a foosball tournament
what the [ __ ] huh
scored early scored early on texas by
the way great to be here on sixth street
i have a a small problem with the names
of all the bars on sixth street it all
has to be something of an impaired
animal
the drunk kitten i'll meet you over at
the limping lizard i'll see you at the
anxious aardvark let's go drink
collegiate
the himalayan sea turtle bar
let's go drink at the palsied puppy
tonight are we seeing what's happening
with hunter here hunter has stepped up
and he's like i it's almost like he
doesn't want to live in texas hunter is
wearing his uh foosball capri pants
today that's right storing magical
powers in that dead big toenail
left foot as soon as you expose your
calves you are uh exposing a lot more
about who you are the person oh hunter
trying to move to the middle
and there he goes also hunter is playing
with an injury he has a hangnail right
and his heart is
okay that was a little shel silverstein
coming at you
oh okay action on table one dan soder
took a an early leave it's 1-1 1-1 on
table 1.
scored again picking each other out
right now doing the doing the
wiggles
three
player
three to zero puncher duncan up three to
zero i don't know how it's possible but
dan soder just pulled his groin
he's working it out
okay table four we've got a two to one
lead on table four
oh hunter duncan almost with another
score
the action is fast table end to end on
table two if you're watching this
closely
texas trying to make a move oh
texas with a strong move
hunter do you have three or two
three three three to one oh they're
pulling this three to one uh poor table
didn't get hunters
texas is playing for texas strong
what what's happening on table four what
who just scored
no you just dropped okay
so first of all he is dropping the ball
into play you don't do that is that
right he's like that's correct usually
you would set it on the five bar just
set it on the five bar but everybody's
godless animal out here he's also the
type of guy that would when he goes
bowling throw it halfway down the lane
he would never do that never do that
great block by hunter all right so who
lost on table three
let's get uh let's get you over here
listen give him a big round of applause
everybody he made it to the second round
were you playing for your country yes
what is your country uh mexico yeah
oleo leolae no chance
no chance of that out there i mean this
is our national sport as you already
know yeah foosball is your naturals it's
actually called bolito fubolito
tiny football that translates to tiny
football i believe if i may tell you
what mexican words are
okay you mean spanish words good jay
great he's speaking mexican ran i don't
think i'm being racist at all okay all
right that's fine okay bit like racist
people i speak tex-mex okay so uh i only
speak in cases
that's right so uh were you disappointed
you seemed like you came into the match
saying i've got confidence and then here
you are i mean they promised us that if
we want this match we will get texas
back but uh
wow that's going to happen
that's an unbelievable promise yeah so
all our hopes are on that guy i don't
know if he lost
did you lose
by the way you know it's bad when mexico
is telling texas they have bad abortion
laws
mexico is like we're allowing it what
are you doing about it
uh well listen it was so nice to have
you you classed it up can i tell you
that yeah amazing thank you so much and
good luck to all that you do sir you
might have lost the game but you came
out best dressed thank you
mama tommy and now for the exact
opposite of the way that you look
sir what in the world happened i know
you're a lawyer sir you've you've you've
done wonders for helping this festival
and keeping it moving and yet you
couldn't move through to the third round
i was throwing some curveballs he was as
you saw dropping it from that's not
allowed that shouldn't be allowed yeah
we can't keep doing that can't drop the
balls you got to set it on the five bar
that's right that's a great it's a great
point it's a bigger issue we now just
gotta do a discussion of baja california
and i don't like it um so uh will you i
did were you preparing to play in the
foosball tournament or were you a late
edition i was
not so but you know that didn't answer
his question at all
i said were you one or the other and you
just said i was not okay good
who won on table two he won you won all
right well hang on the good news for you
is that you will continue to be a mike
lawrence impersonator and i appreciate
that love it for all of your work thanks
sawyer thank you so much
all right texas you lost to hunter
duncan what happened a lot of confidence
he had an excellent shot from the back
that he figured out he really did yeah
you're not the first woman who's told
him that i want you to know that he's
engaged guys it's okay
uh he's good he's really good he's good
so you're someone who plays foosball on
the regular i have i used to like years
ago but today was the first time i've
probably played in like three years so
okay it's gonna be back it's good to be
back is it will you foose again has your
has the foosball fire been lit in your
stomach uh i'm gonna go buy some
sediment and do some wrist exercises and
like train up um and then get back in
there that sounds like you're gonna jump
off for
15 hours roughly let me yeah i try to go
for more like 10. okay
does diet play any part of it for you
who diet
diet no okay good i saw him carb loading
on the voodoo donuts prior to the game
okay he
packed in a few of those uh
yeah i like it i like it thank you dan
soder by the way
dan once again my blood brother
this looks like josh and i look like a
retired x-games athlete
exactly guys what happened out there i
mean the skateboard you couldn't pull
the ollie just you guys totally [ __ ]
up on the five-star what happened wasn't
there just wasn't there on the street
course it wasn't there in the half pipe
thorny go back i love my team i love my
new coaches i mean cooter just puts you
he sets you up really well you just had
your wheels rotated shout out to tony
hawk van margera i know you're going
through a tough time but we're all there
for you bro when you broke your leg we
were all there we signed the cast yeah
and it's a real thing bro bird house for
life bro hey man you sent it when you
were out there and we were just proud of
you dude i suck so bad at foosball you
do you literally do we've given you more
chances than most people
every comic who played in the foosball
tournament and lost tonight will at
least have that moment internally where
they're like at least i can do comedy no
but i'll tell you how i feel in foosball
i feel like mark davis
you mean the like how he looks the owner
of the raiders the ball comes oh i feel
right
opportunities i shouldn't
i look like an idiot what i do well
you're a wonderful dance owner
everybody seven pm at the state cider 7
pm
are we into round three sir all right
round three
it's about to get real it's the final
how many people are left
like can i eight or everyone every table
so there are there's eight people left
this is the quarterfinals right now this
is where things get real this is where
the mental part of the game comes in
this is where the drugs are starting to
kick in this isn't exactly so here we go
let's let's let's line those tables up
okay on table one
okay seth terry cordova that seth
gielbach is
terry oh that's the that's not your girl
yes give it up for terry in the car
terry
oh terry a fan favorite a crowd favorite
she's the person who gets the
bachelorette party going the lone lady
left she's the girl who's like girls
we're going to drink tonight and then
we're going to pedal the bar down the
street
that's her idea
table 2 we have marcus
portman against ryan scott
all right here we go
hunter duncan ryan how many
how many steps you got today buddy
before brad grossman
all the stuff all the steps oh god this
is real okay
here we go no one no one who is left in
this tournament right now kelsey uh is
here by accident all these people are
performers they are players any one of
these guys could take it or women
there's one woman if you don't
i would count hunter as half
i would count hunter is very sensitive
so this woman up front
not afraid to wear there's an argument
on table four we're not quite sure of
the rules
okay here we go action's already going
those people started their games
wow wow he's good i know i know breathe
breathe girl this is
look
this is a moment where you're like why
did i wear that macrame plant hanger as
a cover-up
okay here we go the action on
i'm literally on table four they haven't
gotten past rock paper scissors it's
gonna be a week until this get this
match is done
okay action in the front
okay wow he's got some moves oh down
around the back so that's a wall pass on
to wallpaper very impressive he set it
up in the euro pin now he's going to do
a pull shot pull shot oh off the side
nice
what she's doing is watching and sort of
studying game tape right now and i call
that a scouting report oh darn it number
two it's okay
it's okay take another drink you're not
drunk enough you're not drinking get her
more someone get her more booze right
now
you've got your girls in the back over
there why are they not flying you
someone get her another we need a white
claw on table one
this woman is if life if white claw
became a person
oh look she nice save there
she's blocking it
she's on the defense a lot in this game
tricky yeah by the way he's tricky he's
got a white fan
shot every time oh
big shot for her
block just off to the right side of the
goal table on the actions good table two
a lot of
all right he does
oh he's got all kinds of moves he's got
bank shots he's got bank shots he's got
trick shots those guys are harder to
defend
he's like the kind of guy who's like i'm
gonna give you four violin lessons and
then in the third one he's like let's
have some
red wine
let's just hang out and have some red
wine he's got bank shots he's got trick
shots and all she's got are shot shots
shots
[Applause]
[Laughter]
josh what are you seeing down on table
two this table one right there what are
you seeing on table two these guys i've
seen both guys that have dealt me drugs
here at the festival
they are
a competitive game
oh no i can't smoke right now thank you
it's not that competitive he's up 4-1
and i've seen for nothing
all right here she goes
down four nothing on the front table
here this is weird just kidding ball
game that's a skunk oh my god you've got
work if you sir you've got blanked what
is it like to be on an extended rum
springer
it's everything i could hope for
this guy just playing for the love of
the game straight to the foosball table
you did it man dude you are about you
are everything that is great with texas
i love seeing you out at the shows thank
you for coming out thanks for
participating thank you guys thank you
for being a rabbi we love you so much
to so many of us thank you guys i
appreciate it keep on coming i'll keep
on coming walker texas rabbi right there
give it up
give him some love
i'll see you later tonight brother thank
you so much you lost right
wearing an official foosball shirt oh my
god we have another set of very hard
nipples i'd like to point out yes so so
when they sold you that shirt they did
say look this is also available at a
large you don't need to get the medium i
was in the kids section you're in the
kids section
uh you are not a surprise to us you are
yeah yeah got that he's not supposed to
be in the kids section
uh you you look like you play foosball a
lot did you have you played a lot or in
your youth i experimented with it back
in college sure we all did a little bit
yeah hey that's a phase where we go into
that stuff yeah uh you didn't take your
sunglasses off for the entire match was
that a choice
a strategy
you didn't want him to see your eyes
can't let him know what you're thinking
can't let him see their eyes and look
look what that did for you you lost yeah
okay well you should be really proud of
yourself quarterfinals that's amazing
stuff take that home with you and uh i
hope it gets you laid with the wife
there you go enjoy good luck buddy
that's a good guy flashlight on an
honest phone
i don't want to say that guy's old but
his flashlight's on on his phone always
back pocket back pocket he has to get to
a uh an uno tournament after this
uh table one's still going on we thought
it was over
oh what happened she
is tanked right now she's not oh
simple
thank you wait
wait did you lose yeah all right hang on
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere
all right what are we doing first
the best looking guy here the only
person that that gets laid in this
tournament
yeah i know what does it feel like to be
sexually attractive
to you to everyone everybody here oh
it's uh a lot of pressure i gotta say
it is especially coming from mexico yeah
i mean everyone's like putting me in
this latin lover
i guess yeah you want people to
recognize you for your talents your
foosball and your comedy not your looks
of course and no one's gonna do that sir
i'm sorry no one will do that in your
life just know that
unfortunately you're a piece of meat
a piece of mexican needs yes
you're you're you're delicious yes
you're a little chorizo we love you we
love your work uh did you have fun in
this tournament more fun than you
thought i did uh it was you know
great competition i think that uh you
know i disappointed my country you did
we did
come here with a mission yes we lost
brad
took away
our historic dignity so for the first
time a white man took away the uh the
needs and the and the dreams of people
of color first time okay so it can
happen in this world i am a i am a
person of color you are listen as a
mexican you made it to the quarterfinals
and more importantly you made it across
the border congratulations everybody
congratulations thank you felix all
right mom ma'am
what happened what not over here you're
you're a fan favorite crowd favorite oh
my cheat
we love you i love watching you play she
is the macrame marauder you are amazing
i know i just pulled this out i'm sorry
but i can't believe i got this far and
it's so awesome
and i want to see some ping pong yes
ping pong hey by the way are you the
most fun person in your friend group
like when people invite you over they're
like the party is starting when she gets
here
guilty
guilty you are so fun you're infectious
i love it so much great energy and it's
and it's not a great thing to say
infectious during a pandemic but you are
so infectious your energy just spreads
to everyone your body 77 of this country
is trying to get vaccinated against you
but 23 ain't gonna do it that's right
keep spreading your viral load
everywhere
you said
did you have fun today i had so much fun
of course i got this
you're amazing let's give a round of
applause here she did great she'll be at
the bar
getting two drinks she described this as
an eight ball of foods
[Laughter]
all right let's semi-finally
finally final four and then of course a
finals and then that winner will face
the great kelsey cook and she's a master
it's just unbelievable what she can do
so let's uh get the semifinals out there
yeah let's do them together
on table one and two
seth against ryan here we go
this is this is the match-up that
everybody here came to see this is duke
north carolina this is uh
oklahoma
what's a team that there is a rival of
theirs oklahoma nebraska this is kramer
vs kramer guys happening on this table
and who's on two
hunter dogs
against brad
so clearly the winner of two is going to
lose to the winner of one and that's
okay we understand that at this point
uh greater than
way better than i thought though hunter
has done great okay so we've already
started play on one start play on one
let's keep eyes on table one because
this is good
yeah seth was a ping-pong semi-finalist
so if we ever get like if we ever get
sawdust shuffleboard this guy's going to
[ __ ] blow it out
you lost to junior finals you lost it i
remember you man i really do he's been
in the finals of ping pong
he's a two sport athlete that doesn't
happen a lot for guys
i mean i just love that he's got glasses
lenses from 1996. yes he is he is uh
sponsored by pearl vision
all right the action's hot and heavy on
one we've got two
setting up a pole shot
trying to go long setting up a pull shot
is what josh adamers did last night
stop
oh
but look at seth a great play from a guy
that made his own shoes
out of old sarapa wraps
that he bought at the border there you
go
okay hunter duncan making his mark here
up 2-0
we got a tight race down on table one
table table one looks like the battle
between two different art teachers
it does no they both of these guys cried
during my octopus teacher i want you to
know that and they were both surprised
by how much they cry they're both mr
holland neither of them has an opus
should have gotten more from you guys
should have gotten more from the balcony
i'm really disappointed you guys are
slipping what is the heat getting to you
come on gang well you can't laugh at a
good richard dreyfus joke okay
i actually think table one might go to
the death so uh
here we go i want to say rest in peace
michael k williams because this one's
going down to the wire okay folks here
we go oh wow i think one of the
competitors on table one should be
tested for drugs i think i saw lipitor
in his pocket
josh thank you okay
sometimes josh it as the shadows are
casting over part of the table does that
seem to create an issue on here um i
feel like both of these guys are
completely dialed in that's great i
really do this these are the two that i
would say might be
getting all the way uh up to the kelsey
game now is that a technical term you
just used the kelsey game getting
getting all the way getting all the way
hunter duncan don't uh wow
scores the third goal brad brad brad are
you regretting signing up for this
tournament now
one other thing what other things are
you regretting brad in your life
knowing you guys knowing us yeah that's
a good point fair totally fair fair
enough
all right
a lot of mid-table action happening here
on the front line not enough traffic oh
ryan knew where he was going with that
back of the back of the onion bag
here we go want to put the biscuit in
the basket
wow oh no getting very tricky on one
hunter duncan is one goal away
from putting this away and joining a
finals and an opportunity to play kelsey
cook
ryan brian setting up a pole shot
footwork
wow just
looking for oh
he's got that ball on a string doesn't
he does yeah it's like the harlem globe
great ball control
i'm gonna call him ned lasso that's
right oh
brad grossman one of one of the nicest
people we've known you for a while brad
nice to meet you
bro we gotta ask you the questions what
happened out there you got so far you
look like you were dialed in uh hunter
obviously is a ringer but you look like
you had talent wow it fell apart
what we just saw was i gotta tell you
any time that hunter messed up he was
like oh hunter
and i just uh felt sorry for him yeah
he gets you his mother brad tell people
about the relationship the new cap city
where it's going to be cap city opening
december
in the domain thank you randy
oh we just had
wow five to one victory
right as much
so so guys everyone check out cap city
it's one of the best clubs ever and brad
and mark who are the helium dudes
opening it back up i love those guys
comedy in this town belongs here
we'll see you there at taft city
seth seth you are one of the best i
would say bar game dudes ever uh it's a
tremendous skill i'm i'm sure how much
foosball did you play before you uh
before you got here
in your life 10 years ago i played 10
years ago seth i want to ask you when
there was an active shooter at texas in
the bell tower and you were there
seth i have one question why are you
making it so hard for black people to
vote in the state
he's not
he's not seth you're a wonderful
competitor it really i will say this
what's funny about this randy and i have
been doing the ping pong tournament for
years we've been doing this now for one
year and uh i will say that it's fun and
games in the beginning first couple
rounds it takes concentration to keep
going and move all the way over the
finals how good was the the gentleman
you played ryan he's good
what what does he bring to literally the
table control control control same with
jan jackson seth i love you buddy
thank you
thanks for always participating amazing
give it up for all the competitors that
we've had on the floor today
everybody valiant efforts from everyone
okay
we're into the penultimate finals so
this is almost the finals before the
finals uh and we've got hunter duncan
hey jay thanks for explaining what
penultimate means to people in austin
dumbass i don't want to uh explain it
too much but uh
this hunter has been someone who i don't
think people thought would make it all
the way to the finals but here he is
he's a tremendous comic as well he's the
people's champion he is but he's going
against a man who has a table in his
basement that's what he said that's the
destination got a table in his basement
and bodies buried in the backyard uh
let's get to it the finals before the
finals couldn't be more excited for this
final event gentlemen i mean this is
david and goliath in many ways this is a
tattoo on the leg versus 1980s nba body
here we go now to our finals make some
noise for our final two competitors
hunter duncan and ryan scott
[Applause]
ryan scott's saying give me something to
break 1999 woodstock just watched that
yeah it's the fred durst of uh
of foosball champions okay here we go
lay it down here we go thank you
and the action has started i'm gonna say
this ryan the palp is palpable it's like
a seventh grade dance both guys feeling
each other out right now
and just getting a feel for the board a
lot of shaking going on
that's going to be the disadvantage with
this
quick goal
that wasn't more than 360 though he's
okay okay that was not he knows what
he's doing
annie told hunter where to get the ball
too so that one kelsey that's not the
first time you've said to a man i'll
allow it
[Laughter]
with the euro pin
hitting it so hard the ball just came
back out of the goal all right wow
that's a that's a big goal two nothing
hunter doesn't know where he is right
now he's free falling
he's got to get it back mentally he's
got it into the into ryan zone
trying to put the ryan wearing the
official gear from his world series of
poker tournament that's right
he's got phil ivey shorts on
ball side to side he's going for a pin
and pull setting up another pole
hunter figured it out right there made
the save bring it up oh my god he did
that almost he needed that so much
almost got caught slipping guys
as dmx famously said almost got caught
slipping
been caught stealing to quote
oh you're getting your ass handed to you
bro it's okay you have to look for the
christmas step it up dude
quick shot let's make it happen and
oh
dink haters take a seat i mean we call
that a lazy susan
hunter duncan just gently slipped it in
there
oh another
answer from uh from ryan ryan and he's
just he just has so many moves kelsey
one goal away
oh oh
two shots on the goal and this is game
point right here yep four to one he's
gotta be ready on defense it's gotta be
set up good block
good block by hunters got his men set in
the right spots good luck trying to
match this is about anticipating oh wow
great black again oh hunter duncan oh
great blocks by ryan
hunter trying to jam it in with no
consent
[Laughter]
oh man oh
hunter with a shot ryan with a nice save
with his goalie back oh
let's give him a ride
guys give it up for hunter everybody not
have a foosball table in his basement
he just got engaged uh how do you face
your soon-to-be wife uh letting her know
that you didn't you didn't climb to the
top of the mountain yeah it's not gonna
be easy uh it's gonna be a rough night
yeah i told her comedy was just to get
to this right so and so you've already
set up the gofundme for your therapy for
this i appreciate that yeah uh but are
you actually surprised and happy with
how far you advance in this time i
didn't i hadn't played in years either
so and it showed thank you
that's why you are where you are right
now you got far really yeah i mean this
is for real like in a tournament like
this again you can mess around and get a
couple easy draws and maybe get through
round one or two but you have to have
some skill if you're going to make it to
the penultimate finals which once again
what does pen ultimate mean it's the
finals before great i don't think much
of the fan base here understood what
that meant so hunter great job
congratulations man give it up for
hunter connor duncan a great comic a
great foosball player great convenience
magic dance okay guys so right now we're
gonna have kelsey since she's been
sitting up here and all cooped up she
hasn't been playing these guys been
warming up we're gonna give her a few
minutes on a table to
play stretch it out and then we will get
to the finals so my suggestion is don't
go anywhere get another drink enjoy
yourselves and get ready for the finals
are you guys ready
fury championship which will be an
episode of wrestling yes it'll be in an
episode of wrist and fury uh kelsey is
the champ but we shall see she's got
stiff competition yeah there we go
please subscribe to all things comedy on
youtube where you can see the other 23
episodes of rissa fury they're so funny
we did one she beat both of us big
episode with square
brothers fantastic all right guys finals
coming up let's hear it let's hear this
it's the final countdown
randy the super bowl the world series
the nba finals they don't know what
pressure is yes we are here for a
foosball championship to end all
championships
[Music]
what what a great tournament we had with
the people we have the people's champion
ryan going up against the great kelsey
cook two versions of uh we have every
version of a white person in the finals
and why people like to do hot yoga to
white people who do pilates we've got
them all in this finals it's all here i
think it was gary busey who once said it
is better to have foozed and lost than
than never to have foozed at all so
today we're going to let it all go on
the table and uh kelsey do you want to
explain what is
josh want to just sort of talk about
what's going to happen right now with
kelsey how many rounds so we're gonna be
doing three rounds best of three if
someone cleans it up in two then it's
all over correct or is it three rounds
so we do three rounds the first round
we're gonna play just a straight game to
five yep second round we're going to
make it more interesting because he and
i will both be handicapped nice so we're
going to see what happens with that i
believe it's called physically
challenged but continue fine and i would
call you both handicapable it's not a pc
show where's brad williams i'm sorry
he's standing right next to you that's
how short it is god damn it
he's standing up under the team all
right
speaking of dave matthews which by the
way that was he was the inspiration for
dave matthews uh album under the table
in germany continue continue
and then
third round we're gonna play two ball
okay
and something lance armstrong cannot do
once again
playing two ball and the winner is going
to take all in two ball
winner takes it all loser takes the fall
are you ready for this how do you feel i
feel great
ryan feels i wasn't talking to you ryan
but how do you feel good kelsey how do
you feel you've had a chance to scout
the competition a little bit what do you
think are his strengths ryan and i have
different advantages coming into this
because he has been playing all day yeah
he's warm he's ready in the pocket i've
been able to watch him a little bit yes
you've scouted like i know some of his
shots maybe but he shoots a lot of
different things so yeah that's right
and i talked to him by the bathroom he
said when this ketamine kicks in he's
gonna really have a good time
look this is going to be a battle for
the ages are you guys ready to see some
top
baseball
all right guys good luck to both of our
competitors today good luck and god
bless want to thank you all things
comedy zodiac studios and voodoo donuts
by the way this is uh once again the
venue at atx let's foose baby
[Music]
they're gonna rock paper scissors to see
who drops the ball
um and surprisingly andy cohn is gonna
drop the ball which is weird yeah he has
to be around every ball that drops okay
here we go
ryan has the glasses off
well it's not sunny out all right so
they're feeling each other out as we
said before this is a big ryan's on
offense right now can kelsey block can
kelsey no kelsey's on offense he's sorry
kelsey's on offense kelsey is the black
players ryan is the gold
wow nice block by kelsey up the middle
she's quickly transitioned into defense
she transitioned quicker than caitlyn
jenner here we go next
at least easier wow
sneaks one in snakes one pass that
rattled around the wickets kelsey up one
nothing
ryan doesn't know what it's like to be
behind so far in this tournament
back and forth he lost possession at the
center line kelsey's got
it a little nerve setting in for ryan
right now he's realizing he's up against
a champion someone who knows what she's
doing okay pass oh
save ryan
going for a pull move
she's around the goal now
shut it down darkness setting in on all
of ryan's dreams
can he come back can he summon what it
takes from deep within all competitors
face this oh yes there it is there it is
we have got a game like robert frost he
will not go quietly into that gentle
good night i don't know if that was
wrong that was not robert frost but
robert frost had a lot of bad nights
here we go wind wind becoming a factor
wind always a factor randy in foosball
kelsey passing it oh she took it to the
corner couldn't get it in
ryan has almost took it to the house or
is the israelis say to the
[Music]
i bite you back there oh
right and we're all knotted up guys
kelsey again not used to in many of
these matches
being even this is here we go this is a
real match we've got a real barn burner
here guys
kelsey moving it passing it oh lost
possession
and
setting the ball up by the five
passing through passing it nicely to her
center back and forth
takes a shot at the goal
very quiet
it's dance in the crowd oh there it is
wow
that one
that one was one for the ages that was
like shaquille o'neal when he sees a
pizza that's available to him he just
went for it i was gonna say when he sees
an opportunity to be in a commercial he
just went for it folks shaquille o'neal
does a lot of commercials he's in a lot
of commercials he's the new general and
papa john like how much child support
does shaquille o'neal have to pay
all right
kelsey passing it up getting it up to
herself
ryan setting it up from his back line
kelsey making some moves adjusting his
rides playing with his balls this all
feels like a wow
great block
if this feels like a sped up version of
the great british baking show it does
everybody's moving around only with less
action um
oh
oh big save ryan save ryan
gave him everything he could handle
kelsey felt it she felt the opening and
she went for it good block kelsey back
she's got it now on her back line moving
it around trying to take it forward
she's got it in the middle
ryan with a with a takeaway up the
middle oh
ryan goes up three two three two guys
it is tense up in here we need energy
[Applause]
oh
very fast very fast almost didn't have
time to set it up it almost josh it
almost felt like she didn't mean to do
that yeah it looked like a computer that
was another mistake they weren't paying
attention excuse me stay in the game
sometimes it's better to be lucky than
to be good like most comedians parents
they weren't paying attention here we go
kelsey's got it on her middle line she's
passing it through back and forth
looking for an opening
again like josh anna meyers looking for
an opening here we go
back and forth ryan trying to make a
move it's questioning right now guessing
where he's going to go can she block
can she fill the space
the space between again two dave
matthews references not proud of it not
proud of it great block by kelsey she's
gained possession
she's like ants marching out there what
am i doing oh my god
josh had a meyer's hat to the back he
needs better view at this he's down low
josh
all right she's she tried to get it up
to her front offense and jocking for
position wasn't able to do it this is
he's got the ball on his his defensive
line
maybe back to the goalie back to the
wall
pass it to the front this is like me and
randy in high school not a lot of
scoring
exactly but a lot of jockeying around
and a lot of hard work that's right
ryan's got it on the offensive kelsey
trying to mount a defense she's almost
taunting him great big save on her
defensive line
didn't even let it get to the goal line
that's right
again like high school for us here we go
passing it through wow
all the way through the back line could
have gotten through as a as a mistake
ball
we're knotted up at three guys the
tension is high kelsey has possession
he's gotta be looking maybe looking for
a score from back
doesn't even want to set up the offense
back and forth oh my god just playing
with the ball
toying with his emotions exactly
wow wanted something from the side take
it ryan with nice defense on his front
line you know when you can get your
front guys to play defense that's what
oh right through she's got it on the
middle defense wins championships randy
oh and there it is
out of chelsea takes round one
ryan
ryan let's talk about it for a minute
what did what did she present to you as
a challenge the most she's just so fast
with her hands she's got real fast hands
i feel like a disappointment to my
children no you're not a disappointment
you're a disappointment to your children
for other reasons that has nothing to do
with it you need to spend more time with
them but you know what it's like even
when you've had two drinks okay don't
don't read a story to them
but she's got really fast hands and she
knows how to play even from the back
line as well what were you trying to do
in that game that you felt was maybe
successful
i felt like i had some opportunities
that uh didn't capitalize on on the on
the three bar yeah
her her zone's really good so the i've
been scoring a lot from the two bar
against other opponents so um
try some different things next game okay
good listen this is a three-round match
right you don't want to get beaten twice
by the same loss so come back round two
we're back to zero are there any new
rules to round two what are we doing in
round two all right kelsey first of all
before you get to the rules how did you
feel were you surprised at the
competition that he gave you yeah he's
really good he is really good it's fun
to play against him uh
[Music]
you say that and i don't believe you
yeah no i'm just kidding it's like when
someone said like kelsey asked ask me
how her one-woman show was just ask me
how how was my one-point show now you're
just someone else we're talking
like the higher our voices go the worse
it is now ask us how his one woman how
his one-man show was ryan's one-man show
it was really good it was really good i
was shocked at how good it
was went low so when i asked you was he
a good player what would you say
absolutely see your voice voice went
down i trust it are we in for an amazing
round two
that's [ __ ] okay so let's get some
energy
[Music]
energy energy
you guys we're watching a real match
happen here so now what are the
handicaps for round two so ryan and i
are going to come over to the spinner
here so on risk of fury we always pick
handicaps here's the thing we've never
had somebody on the show who is an
actual foosball player right so usually
i just get severely handicapped and they
get an advantage to try and make it
easier but you and i are both going to
get handicapped to see what happens
aren't his shoes a handicap
absolutely
a problem for my eyes my eyes have been
burning right so you're saying another
handicap beside his footwear okay
yeah
okay so let's see what's going on here
josh can i give you back this mic josh
you
do you want josh to do the rolling so
that you can to roll through it i'll
make it official and by the way we are
also getting the lotto numbers for
southern texas right now josh by the way
rolling rolling the machine and also
rolling on e right now so i am high as
balls right
you're on the left pick it i'll pick it
you pick it so this this is for kelsey
right this is gonna be her handicap
b17 no stop josh come on
miss it it's uh one
one green one
so kelsey will explain
so that means i can only score from my
back rods oh
gosh
wow okay i don't know i don't know roll
it and spin it for uh ryan here
lock
lock it up guys lock it up if we can
lock this i don't know why we're having
such a trouble running i will say one of
these in there means that ryan has to
get a vasectomy now hang on a second
you can't stop someone that potent okay
green two green two what does that mean
kelsey
that means that ryan has to play with
only one hand and standing on one leg oh
okay
wow this is going to be
this is gonna be like two drunk people
on sixth street trying to make love
a lot of stumbling around no one's using
all of their faculties everyone
questioning uh if either of them are
gonna make it through the night that's
right so here we go
round two you guys ready you ready
let's do it
round two
[Music]
ryan one
on one leg with only one arm
rock paper scissors here we go
oh my god and to jump around in that
footwear again i don't mean to belabor
the footwear but
his footwear is the physical
manifestation of a sandals resort
it's all inclusive
all right she's looking at him hopping
around
hopping around she's got a score from
only her one can she score
oh my god ryan just literally
he's being he's being so deliberate
right now
she's gotta pass it okay so kelsey's
gotta pass it all the way back
oh my god she does not okay
gotta pass it all the way back here we
go from the one slot
oh
there it was right there someone just
said are we playing the one
that's a drunk guy who's not allowed to
be in here who just said that no there's
a bar you're allowed to be drunk right
sir sir you're welcome i'm sorry
okay sorry that today you broke your
sobriety okay here we go
kelsey back to one as we say in the film
business oh my god
playing i want you off the wall if
you're playing the wall so josh watch
you what you what you want
this game is so intense right now this
game is so intense this game is so
intense josh has only checked checked
his instagram four times okay it's very
intense
josh you got 137 likes oh wow
twitter is blowing up about this right
now guys this is this is a twitter
moment as they say one foot hirachi
sandal is trending on twitter right now
okay kelsey back
back she's setting up lining up for a
good one but again both feet are on the
ground she's very grounded
she's emotionally grounded too
i don't know if you know this randy but
kelsey broke her wrist a few months ago
and so she is coming back from an injury
yeah she's not letting that hurt her
right now the doctor said she may never
fooze again
doctor said she may never walk again and
it's weird because it's a wrist injury
you're going to the wrong doctor
that's why you never go to a podiatrist
jay did i ever tell you about there was
a a sign of a
a foot clinic in silver lake
and this was a rotating sign and on one
foot it one sign it was like a happy
foot the other side was a sad foot
the sad foot was a foot with a face
and there was a bandage on the big toe
that was on his head and then the foot
had legs and feet so the foot had feet
the foot had feet and then the foot was
on crutches for his foot feet so the
foot
but there was just a bandage around the
toe which is so the foot feet were fine
the foot feet were fine yet he was on
crutches
so what does that say to you about that
this foot clinic can't diagnose [ __ ]
there you go
on crutches for a bandage on his head
that's right that's right
oh wow ryan coming back refute refusing
to get skunked that is a competitor
refusing to lay down on one leg
by the way one leg this is how we all
feel sometimes
we all feel like we're hopping around on
one leg trying to score from the back
line
it's okay guys wow
all right ball seems to be trapped right
here
guys we're lying trying to one
run and if i may right now the crowd is
electric yeah i just want to say
i mean the crowd really influencing
what's happening in the action no one no
one seems to have home field advantage
right
do you know that there's a bar at lax
called home turf
oh
moly
nice
got it's three to two two to two two to
two no three uh two to two two to two
there's a bar at lax called home tour a
sports bar by the way who's going to lax
to go watch their sporting events that's
my home turf it's my home lax terminal
six that's where i watch all my football
games it's my home turn oh
kelsey i felt that it went right across
going in right across the goal mouth
always a disappointment when the balls
cross the mouth and don't go in i know
guys
kelsey lining everything up
ryan
hopping it hopping mad right now
about to make a move
about to make a move oh
kelsey
trying to gain control ryan gets it back
he's got it he's lining up his shot
oh great save by kelsey that was point
blank range
of course she can't go from point break
range because that is her handicap in
this match playing from the back line
that's right she's
wow
like lin-manuel miranda she's not
throwing away her shot
like
now you know what if if this game goes
any longer i might start singing george
washington's coming home
all right
it's lining it up kel's oh
slow roller slow roller
we call that the old mexican dribbler
north of the border about ready to drop
down
ryan setting things up once again kelsey
allowed to play defense with her upper
players but not allowed to score
close
she can stop it
ryan getting tired on that one foot
this is a lot of people didn't
understand or realize how much of an
endurance sport this would be
oh great saving my right big save big
save but that's just great player
placement
he's around the goal
protecting his house
he's like adt
he never comes when you call this right
he charges you [ __ ] always calls the
cops and charge you [ __ ] 100 to show
up all right here he goes
on the back row
and you're like oh wait you're a
security guard for adt boy i trust you
you couldn't even be honest
is that it
there you go that's all game ball game
round two
by the way ryan you can get on that
other leg now all right thank god let
the blood go back to leg so now
so she won the first two ryan uh what
was obviously the the one foot or the
one hand was the challenge it was the
foot right
yeah it was the foot although i
kept wanting to grab things with the
other hand that's right is this that air
jack i mean that that was that was
harvey weinstein's problem anyway i just
kept wanting to grab things with the
other hand
uh so your handicap was being on one
foot and only playing with one arm but
and yet you tried to compensate that by
not seeing race i appreciate that yeah
thank you thank you uh tough game but i
thought you it was amazing that you got
two in there that's incredible thank you
so going up for the third round kelsey
by the way great job what was the
hardest part for you in that game
uh
ryan's got great defense yeah so
it is obviously the hardest shot to make
from the back yeah to go through many
more people yeah
so yeah ryan rayne did a great job okay
great so third round what are we gonna
see okay so third round we play a game
called two ball so there are two balls
in play you have to score both to get a
point if we each score one it's a wash
there you go
first of five wins
here's the thing so usually we do pretty
humiliating punishments on the show for
the people that
we have had a can of spam
sitting in the sun sitting in the sun
which by the way was one of my favorite
novels spam in the sun
by dr seuss so
the loser has to take a giant
bite of that spam in the sun
oh it's hot
spam hot sun spam come on guys okay
ready you guys ready for this [ __ ]
this is for all the spam
josh how you doing i'm doing great man
i'm excited for that spam josh has the
peyote kicked in yet it's
full blast full blast okay are you
seeing native americans good i am
love spam foosball scattered on dawn's
highway bleeding
ghost crowd the young child's fragile
eggshell mind
that was weird okay
all right we don't know who's going
first here there really isn't a going
first because they're both going at the
same time
two balls playing at the same time a lot
of scoring randy and i don't know what
that's like okay all right here we go
this is a lot of action
this is crazy like trying to i don't
know kelsey just got one in she's going
for the second
here she goes so it's almost a mess at
the beginning you just gotta hold on and
then you can focus on the other one it's
like thanksgiving with your republican
uncle it's a mess at the beginning
okay so you only gave yourself one point
for that
you have to score two to get one
two one guys we just brought up the hot
spam cannon i'm telling you right now it
smells terrible
this is what's at stake guys you just
smells like big j okarson's
undercarriage ladies and gentlemen
there we go oh god and here
all right should we open it up to let it
air out no definitely not
i think oh
kelsey with two right
she's got two
no he scored one she scored once a wash
no one gets the point it's a he said she
said situation guys
who are you gonna believe
and i say the victim that's where's one
there's one kelsey's got one she's gonna
try and drop the other one in
[Music]
wow
great save on defense
she's from the back row
let me get some action from the back
section here we go
windy body rock and not protection oh
come on
ryan does not want
this is for literally all the marbles
wow
ryan great block great block
kelsey great block on the back line
still controlling it
kelsey's got on the back line she's got
her men back there
and we call them men but they could be
just women with shaved heads yeah oh
darn it no one scored on that what's
going on that was a wash guys that was
the watch is this festival ends this
evening this game should take most of
that okay
two balls enter one ball leaves
um why do i feel like we're watching a
documentary on the nexium cult let's do
it oh wow ryan looking for a second one
looking to score he's yelling loudly for
ryan that's right
ryan's got his own fan club here the p
he's the people's champion it's the
people's choice
he's feeling it feeding off the energy
of the crowd great block
great block
so that last come on ryan from whoever
said it was more scolding than
supportive i just want to say i'm on
ryan come on ryan what did i tell you
hit it right
there's rooting and then there's
scolding oh good save ryan save ryan on
the back line he always seems to be in
the right place at the right time
except for when it's time to pick up his
kids that's right again we talked about
this guys
wow deep shot
kelsey had her men set up beautifully in
the back line
she's moving it around
he's getting very technical
ryan big save
on his front line he's moving it sliding
it feeling it
owning it
now apologizing for it here we go oh
he took a shot took his shot but she was
right there with all of them and he says
it again another shot
wow
big shot big save kelsey good zone work
as ryan said ball's scooting around ryan
has it again
trying his best he's trying to move it
did we mention he's got a table in his
basement we did wow there's a point
off dividends
dividends
the table his wife told him to throw
away and sell on craigslist that's right
turns out it actually is working out
it's groundhog's day
and you know what that means six more
weeks of open carry guys
it's texas gang it's texas get on board
wow
you almost want to hide one ball get the
other one in and then you can focus on
the other one
watch out down below there we go
set one ball wow there's one oh ryan
looking to get the second kelsey does
not want to let this happen
[Applause]
i've never wished for a rain to lay more
in my life that's right josh
josh just placed several calls to the
person that is dog sitting his dog
leg is doing fine
tell lika i love her
what kind of a name is leica by the way
lekka lecka it's
that's why i have the tattoo right there
all right fine whatever we get it you
got a lot of ink it's pretty hip it's
hit thank you
kelsey playing it back to herself
big shot ryan always there to block
he's he's really playing that front line
tough almost almost that was a chance to
score right there kelsey has it back and
forth
he's like december matumbo with internet
trolls blocking everyone yep finger
wagging all the way look taking the time
to have cocky he's having fun yeah you
know he's enjoying himself yeah buddy
wow that's another point okay so
kelsey's down 2-1 what's our time how
much time
all right
two balls
in ryan's zone
here we go
oh so close right across the goal across
the gold mouth
as the crowd checks their instagram
collectively
kelsey's setting up for chance of what's
the wi-fi come up from the crowd
wow
oh trying to put it in the corner
it's just a free-for-all up the front it
is a free brawl
free for all guys this is the type of
action we came and paid to see and of
course nobody paid anything that's right
except for these people oh there's one
there's one in she's got
she must protect this house to close to
quote under armour
kelsey's got her fan club oh
it's a wash gang it's a wash this is a
wash there's a tie if it's this game
will be continued at the 2022 moon tower
comedy festival
so get your passes now guys let me say
this if a tie is like kissing your
sister a tie at foosball is like [ __ ]
your dog
in front of your sister that's right
oh kelsey with a shot all right all
right
ryan looking to get another get a 3-1
lead on him
oh
not not on my watch is what she just
said she said no um she said no
she say no here she go here we go
back and forth back and forth oh
one kelsey trying to even it up
as opposed to [ __ ] around she is not
yeah she is not she's taking this thing
very seriously
trying to block setting up her defense
now she's got it to her back line
here we go
not a lot of talking going on
oh
off the back row he had a defense
perfectly
she he's not giving her a lot of room
he's not giving her an inch
yet she wants to take a mile here we go
look at her
look at her just passing it back and
forth almost playing with it but wow he
had his defense set up
he was set up in the middle oh
wow
could she go off the wall this is my
thing could she look for a for a
favorable bounce off the wall
maybe a shot to a deflection if you will
guys
this game is very tight being played
between the lines this is being betrayed
between
i don't know what i'm saying anymore me
either
i've lost the ability to talk i've lost
the ability to think i understand
highway hypnosis now
i understand the show ice road truckers
now is that weird
jason how much
wow
ryan's middle men his five line has
saved him many many times here today
this is like the irishman you can
appreciate it but you just want it to
end
rip of the night dude
rip of the night
and it's daytime so here we go thank you
josh
yeah
it gets the second one evens it up right
evens it up
yeah yeah you got both you got both mark
that score two two two two only 12 more
goals to go
it's like the classic like after 14
comics only 11 more comics to go
where are we at flappers folks anyway
gang
oh
did that go in no it did it did it went
in
again something was spoken a lot of
times in high school for me did that is
it in isn't it did that go in
it is okay good is everybody having fun
that was what i would also that follow
that up with is everybody's having
[Applause]
are you okay with this just a heads up
uh terry from earlier has had 14 more
white claws
she is
the problem is she's driving transpo for
the festival
terry i need a left
tara's like where show you going to let
me just try to put a ficus in my shirt
oh terry come on oh god close close
kelsey trying to shut this thing out
shut it down
all right across the goal mouth ryan
with a big save super close
action is tight
the action yep wow it is end to end
randy that's it
here we go sliding through a lot of
movement a lot of movement by the
players oh all the way down there it is
that's it
now the action is tighter than the
lingerie they force the waitresses to
wear here
let them wear jeans is what we're trying
to say guys remember bad new bears let
them play let them wear jeans let them
wear jeans or a comfortable yoga pants
that's it here we go
there's one in is one in one in one in
ryan ryan's got one in
kelsey setting up our defense
ryan off the wall
there comes some
back and forth she sees what he's doing
in case you were worried
next one wins next next point wins
you guys
i'm calling this i'm calling this match
lady macbeth there's so many washes in
here out out brief ball
kelsey tasting blood
one
this is it here we go
chelsea to win it finish him
kelsey to win it i heard one man calling
her chelsea kelsey to win it
someone yelled sweep the leg i don't
know what that means
[Music]
wash
wash ryan refusing to go down jay did
you call him brian
brian is playing phantom ryan has played
so long we're adding a b to the front of
his name
oh there's one there's one
kelsey putting the pressure on
the spam is
ready
oh
ball game ball game
unbelievable but down to the wire
make some noise for the winner kelsey
cook everybody
oh here we go i will open the sam for
opening the stamp guys
oh my god that is a that is a pink you
just don't see in society
how do you feel
you feel pretty good okay looking
forward to the spam here we go you look
like you i'll honestly eat that on the
regular by the way the sponge i don't
know that i've ever actually had spam
the sponginess with this i i
just go ahead you fought val i almost
feel like it's i'm sad you have to do
this but oh my god it does not smell
good i bet it's gonna taste great it's
probably like a minivan you think you're
going to hate it and then it's amazing
here we go he's eating the spam of life
put it in your mouth here we go
[Music]
getting in adding injury to insults
oh my god give it up for ryan ryan keep
it going for ryan fighting valiantly and
then taking his medicine the people's
champion kelsey that was an amazing
amazing job how did you feel i mean was
it harder than you thought it would be
or judging by how he played earlier
i knew it was going to be hard yeah he
was who we thought he was yeah holy [ __ ]
well we have some hardware to give out
uh for our top fan for ryan uh josh
hademyers can you give him this
medal right here for sure where's ryan
let's go back out here these are amazing
he's the top is that top fan that's top
fan yeah there you go
great job top comedian top comedian who
went super going he's going backwards
spam
a true austin gem a true austin jam and
then the winner of the kelsey cook
invitational memorial tournament i can't
believe you're they're pronouncing you
dead now but kelsey cook this was so
much fun today we learned a lot we saw
everyone left it out on the tables uh
any final words final thoughts put it
into a historical context for us
oh my god do you guys want to do this
again in another year
okay
thank you thank you guys so much for
coming out and again big thank you to
colleen and lisa all things comedy
zodiac studios voodoo donuts thank you
guys so much big hand for them they're
incredible this is guys we raised so
much money for charity today i can't
wait uh but thank you so much we are the
scholar brothers she is kelsey cook the
champion of rissa fury he's josh adam
myers we had a great time we'll see you
guys the rest of the time take care
everyone thank you and good night
[Music]
you